actually it's kind of interesting i
think both sides kind of imply that
so the
the people who are against the vaccine
are dumb for not trusting science and
the people who are for the vaccine
are called dumb
for trusting science the scientific
nobody wins yeah
and they both kind of have a point
like because because you can always it's
like a glass half full or half empty
because you can always look at um
like science from a perspective of
certain individuals that don't represent
are perhaps not greatest leaders
almost like political leaders there's a
lot of you know i've
yesterday went on a whole rant
against i said a lot of positive things
about anthony fauci before i went on a
rant against him
because ultimately
you know i think he failed as a leader
and i know it's very difficult to be a
leader but i still wanted to hold him
accountable for that
as a great communicator of science and
as a great leader what what do you think
you do right i'm curious
uh
so
the core of the problem
is
the
several characteristics of the way he
was communicating to the public so one
is the general in authenticity
uh
two is a thing that
it's very hard to put into words but
there are certain ways of speaking to
people
that sounds like you're hiding something
from them
that sounds like you're full of
that's the authenticity piece like it
sounds like you're not
um really speaking to the full truth
um of what you know and that you did
some shady in your past
you're
trying to hide so that's a way of
communicating that i think the internet
and people in general are becoming much
better at detecting as like you said
they're good bs detection yeah good bs
detectors uh then
but contributing to that is speaking
from authority
speaking um with with uh with authority
and confidence where
neither is deserved
so
first of all nobody's in authority on on
this new virus right we're facing a
deadly pandemic and thr in especially in
the early stages it was unclear how
deadly it would be
it was unclear probably still unclear
fully how it's transmitted the full
dynamics of the virus
the full
the full understanding of which
solutions work and not how well masks of
different kinds work
how easy or difficult it is to create
tests how many months or years is going
to take to create a vaccine
uh
how well in history or currently do uh
quarantine methods or lockdown methods
work how you know what are the different
data mechanisms
that are
data collection mechanisms that are
being implemented what are the clear
plans they need to
uh happen what the epidemiology that's
happening what is the uncertainty around
that
um
then then there's the geopolitical stuff
with with china you know like what uh
uh i you know personally believe there
should have been much more openness
about the the origins of the virus
whether a leak from a lab or not i think
communicating that you're open to these
ideas
is actually the way
to get people to trust you that you're
legitimately open to ideas that are very
unpleasant that go against the
mainstream
showing that openness is going to get
people to trust you when you finally
uh decrease the variance in your
uncertainty like decrease uncertainty
and have we still have a lot of
uncertainty but this is the best course
of action vaccines still have a lot of
uncertainty around them mrna is a new
technology but we have increasing
amounts of data and here's the data
sources and like laying them out in a
very clear way
of this is the best course of action
that we have now we don't know if it's
the perfect course of action but it's by
far the best course of action and that
would that would come from a leader that
has earned the capital of of trust from
people i mean i think
in recent history the worst pandemic is
1918 flu right
but that's mainly because we didn't know
what to do we didn't have many tools at
our disposal and that was tied up with
world war one that's right that's right
so the the leadership there i mean but i
don't know what what is a lot of deaths
right and any one person is someone's
family so to them it's a lot right
but that logic we don't apply that logic
generally
because there's a lot of people
suffering and dying throughout the world
and we turn turn the other way all the
time and that's the story of history so
saying saying you all of a sudden what
bothers me though i mean personally i
don't like anyone dying anywhere but and
especially considering what
technology we're able to muster yet we
still kill each other it's just a
dichotomy to me
yeah but i mean this is the what is the
paul farmer uh
there's these great stories i mean
that's that's the
that's the um
that's the burden of
being in health care being a doctor
is
you have
to help you can't help but help a person
in front of you who's hurting sure
but you also are burdened by the
knowledge
that you helping them you spending money
and effort and time on them
means you're not going to help others
and you cannot possibly allocate that
amount of time to everybody so you're
choosing which person lives and which
person dies
sure and you're doing so the reason
you're helping the person in front of
you because is because they're in front
of you and so the reason right now we
care a lot about kovid is because the
the eye of the world has turned to covet
but we're not seeing all the all the
other atrocities going on in the world
they're not necessarily related to
deaths they're related to suffering
human suffering which you could argue is
worse than death
prolonged suffering of course so there's
all there's all these questions and and
the the fundamental question
here is are we overreacting to kovid in
our policies so
this is the
when we turn our eye and care about this
particular thing and not other things
are we dismissing the pain that business
owners who've lost their businesses are
going to feel and then the long
talking about long covid the long-term
effects economic effects on the millions
of people that will suffer that suffer
financially but also suffer from their
dreams
being completely collapsed so a lot of
people seek
gain meaning from work and if you take
away that work
there's anger that can be born there's
pain and so what does that lead to that
can lead to the
rising up of charismatic leaders that
channel that anger towards destructive
things that's been done throughout
history so you have to balance
that with the policies that you have and
kovid and then
i mean uh very much my main opposition
to uh
fauci is not on the details but the
final result which is i just observe
that there's a significant decrease in
trust in science
as uh
not not the institution but the various
sort of mechanisms of science i think
science is both beautiful and powerful
and the reason why we have so many
amazing things and such a high quality
of life
and
distrust in that that the thing we need
now to get out of all the troubles we're
in
continue getting out of the troubles
we're in is science the scientific
process broadly defined like innovation
to technological innovation scientific
innovation all of that
distrust in that is is uh is totally the
wrong thing we need and so anybody who
gets in
who uh causes a distress in science to
me
um
you know um
carries the responsibility of that
and uh should be in because the response
means should be fired should be should
be
or at least uh
openly have to carry the burden of that
of having caused of that kind of level
of mistrust now it may be unfair to
place it on any one individual
but you have to uh i think in your
pocket the the book stops at the top
like
the leaders dude no no there's a clear
leader here yes absolutely so even if
it's not directly his fault
you know he has to carry and
carry the price of that
do you think we should
at this point say okay we have vaccines
you can decide whether you take them or
not let's move forward
maybe you can help me understand this
because it seems like
why is that not the right solution
completely open society the vaccines at
least in the in the united states as i
understand
are widely available
so
this is the american way you have the
decision to make if you have
conditions that make you worried to get
coveted and go to the hospital
then you should get vaccinated because
here's the data that shows that it's
much less likely for you to die
right if you take if you get vaccinated
if you don't want to get vaccinated
because you're worried about a long-term
effects of vaccine that you don't have
to but then you suffer the consequences
of that
and that's it
so i here's what i think is driving
the i think it's all about kids
right
because they're going to go back to
school in the fool and many of them
can't be vaccinated right so
if they get infected they do have less
frequency of disease but it's not zero
they do get sick and they can have
long-term
consequences and
at that age it would be
a shame right and not even their choice
they can't decide
to get vaccinated or not because they
can't have access to it so i think that
would that's what would drive my
efforts to try and get more people at
least in is vaccinated
but i might be wrong it may not be that
you